bonsoir et bienvenue très heureuse de
vous retrouver dans Ça vous regarde ce
soir jusqu'où l'Europe soutiendra
l'Ukraine bonsoir Nicolas tzer
bonsoirê notre grand témoin ce soir
spécialiste des questions
internationales et stratégiques l'Europe
à l'URE des choix sommet crucial à
Bruxelles sur l'adhésion de l'Union mais
aussi sur l'aide financière et et
militaire à kiief on va y revenir le
tout sous le regard de Vladimir Poutine
plus serein plus confiant que jamais il
est sorti du silence longuement
aujourd'hui votre analyse tout à l'heure
dans la deuxème partie notre grand débat
ce soir sur la pénurie de main- d'œuvre
dans notre pays beaucoup de secteurs ne
trouvent pas preneur le projet de loi
immigration devait régler le problème en
régularisant les sans papiers dans les
métiers en tension mais cet article a du
plomb dans l'aile depuis le rejet du
texte la mesure est-elle mornée nous en
débattons dans un instant avec mes
invités enfin nos affranchis ce soir le
monde dans tous ses é Isabelle laasser
le billet philo Nathan de ver et puis
Bourbon express elsamondinava à la fin
de cette émission voilà pour le menu on
y va Nicolas Tenzer ça vous regarde top
[Musique]
générique couvreur aide à domicile
plombier chaudronnier serrurier ou
médecin autant d'exemples de métiers en
tenstion qui ne trouvent pas preneur
dans notre pays la difficulté de
recrutement elle touche un grand très
grand nombre de secteurs on va faire le
point dans cette émission pourtant
depuis l'adoption de cette fameuse
motion de rejet préalable sur la loi
immigration et bien la mesure phare la
régularisation des sanspiers dans ces
métiers en tension à du plomb dans
l'aile et cette commission mixte
paritaire va sceller son sort lundi soir
bonsoir Fanta bereté merci d'être là
vous êtes député renaissance de Paris
porte-parole du groupe macroniste à
l'Assemblée vous déb B ce soir avec
Annie Genevard bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue
à vous députés les républicains du dou
vous siégez vous siégerez lundi 17h dans
cette fameuse CMP sur lesquel tous les
projecteurs seront braqués commission
mixte paritaire pour votre groupe les
républicains la droite est en position
de peser si vous pouvez nous dire et
bien quelles sont au moins vos
conditions sur cet article c'est un plus
pour ce débat bonsoir Pascal Briss
bonsoir merci d'être là président de la
Fédération des acteurs de la solidarité
ancien directeur de l'OFPRA l'office
français pour la protection des réfugiés
et des apatrides malheureusement un
restaurateur manuel hortier devait être
des nôtres il a dû il a dû nous quitter
pour des raisons personnelles il y a
moins de 2 minutes mais on va voir quand
même un reportage dans un restaurant
dans quelques instants sur le terrain
Nicolas Tenzer si vous avez des
questions c'est un sujet concernant
n'hésitez pas on commence par planter le
décor la pénurie de main-dœuvre touche
toute l'Europe et oui on n'est pas les
seuls alors soyons clair avec Tibo
hoc
bonsoir mon cher thbao bonsoir Miriam
bonsoir à tous ravi de vous accueillir
alors régularisation des travailleurs
dans les métiers en tension débat en
France mais pas seulement oui alors j'ai
bien écouté les républicains le
rassemblement national ces derniers
jours et soyons clair s'il y a une
mesure qui justifie leur opposition à la
loi immigration c'est bien celle-ci on
peut pas avir des mesures de fermeté des
mesures qui sont un appel d'air
supplémentaire pour pour l'immigration
ce projet loi dont vous savez que nous
lui reprochions de créer une des plus
grandes filières
d'immigration depuis le regroupement
familial alors appel d'air filière
d'immigration évidemment on comprend que
tout cela est à proscrit et qu'il faut
au contraire fermer les Vanes comme
l'ont fait des gouvernements qui ont été
élus sur des discours similaires en
Europe tenez prenez l'exemple de
l'Italie de Georgia mélonie la
présidente du conseil élue sur une ligne
anti-immigration il y a un an et bien
elle vient d'annoncer c'est regarder
qu'elle va faciliter le recours au
travailleurs étrangers face aux pénuries
d'emploi alors j'ai cru d'abord avoir
Malu mais non ce sont les faits son
gouvernement vient de publier un décret
qui prévoit tenez-vous bien 136000
permis de travail pour les étrangers
cette année 151000 en 2024 165000 en
2025 total plus de 450000
régularisations dans les trois
prochaines années mais alors que se
passe-t-il précisément chez nos amis
italiens alors il se passe que le pays
fait face à une immense pénurie de main-
d'œuvre les décrets dont je viens de
parler font la liste des métiers en
tension l'hôtellerie la construction les
transports et bien d'autres face à ses
besoins le gouvernement autorise
l'immigration pour le travail en
provenance d'une trentaine de pays cela
va de l'Algérie au Japon en passant par
le Sénégal et le Guatemala la demande
est-elle que le ministère de l'Intérieur
a mis au point une procédure en ligne
vous la voyez une sorte de 24 heur
chrono baptisé click day 24 heur pendant
les les organisations professionnelles
peuvent formuler leur demande alors la
dernière édition a lieu il y a 2 jours
résultat pour 136000 permis disponible
il y a eu plus de 260000 demandes c'est
bien la submersion oui mais dans les
demandes des patrons alors est-ce que
c'est une exception que se passe-t-il
ailleurs en Europe ou al c'est vrai que
j'ai peut-être pris un pays encore un
petit peu trop laxiste en la matière
allons voir ce que fait la la Hongrie
tenait en mars dernier le Premier
ministre Victor Orban a fait un discours
qui a surpris tout le monde il a déclaré
que le pays allait avoir besoin de
500000 nouveaux
travailleurs et évoqué la nécessité de
faire venir des travailleurs étrangers
une nouvelle loi a d'ailleurs été votée
dans la foulée qui ouvre les vannes cet
été elle prévoit d'ouvrir un statut de
travailleur invité facilement obtenable
sans même avoir besoin d'un avis
officiel des autorités alors à ce stade
miram de deux choses l'une soit les
dirigeants populistes sont schizophrènes
soit nous sommes face à un problème
structurel en Europe ou alors en France
quelle est la situation alors les
chiffres sont à peu près les mêmes il y
a 500 100000 emplois non pourvus dans le
pays l'an dernier environ 50000 titres
de séjour pour motif professionnel nt
été délivrés les métiers tentions sont
très nombreux dans le pays on y retrouve
évidemment he les services à la personne
le bâtiment les artisans chaudronniers
sererers forgeron mais plus étonnant
regardez chercheurs ingénieurs cadre de
banque même dans certaines régions alors
que faire régulariser peut-être c'est le
sens du fameux article de la loi mais
est-ce l'ultime solution et bien ce
matin le ministre de l'Économie Bruno Le
Maire a laissé entendre que non il y a
un vrai choix politique à faire est-ce
que nous faisons comme Madame mélonie ou
est-ce que nous formons et nous
qualifions pour que ce soit nos propres
jeunes qui occupent ses emplois ma
réponse elle est très claire ce qui se
passe en Italie doit être un message
d'alerte allons chercher ceux qui n'ont
pas d'emploi dans notre pays voilà myiam
alors immigration ou compte formation je
vous laisse en débattre avec vos invités
merci beaucoup thibo c'était absolument
limpide je vais commencer avec vous
Annie jeunevard parce que c'est
intéressant quand même s'il y a bien des
pays qui ont gagné sur la l'immigration
la zéro immigration c'est bien c'est
bien l'Italie et et la Hongrie quand
vous voyez que même ces pays-là sont
obligés de régulariser des travailleurs
sans papier dans les secteurs en tension
qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire alors
plusieurs choses d'abord regardons la
situation de notre pays nous avons plus
de 5 millions de demandeurs d'emploi
5300000 demandeurs d'emploi et sur ce
chiffre il y en a 3 millions qui sont en
catégorie A qui sont donc
employables quand on considère que il y
a effectivement beaucoup d'emplois non
pourvu il y a en même temps beaucoup de
gens qui sont en demande d'emploi donc
on a un vrai sujet ça c'est la première
remarque que m'inspire votre reportage
la deuxième remarque c'est que on a
aussi besoin d'une manœuvre qualifiée et
dans le texte de loi qui va être l'objet
de la CMP lundi il y a des dispositions
pour des cartes de séjour pluriannuel
pour des talents salariés qualifiés il y
a des cartes de séjour talent
professionnel de profession médical on a
aussi besoin de changer un peu le prof
vous parlez d'inigration choisie là
c'est ça et pas d'intégration par le
travail et et alors bien sûr le travail
est très intégrateur mais ce qui doit
nous inciter à la réflexion tout de même
c'est que la part d'étrangers
en demande d'emploi au chômage très
important mais il y a un sujet
économique et ça vous l'avez alors
malheureusement on n' pas notre restaur
par mais ils vous diront on a tout
essayé malgré même les Hauses de salair
il y a un sujet rapport au travail
incontestablement condition le covid le
covid a beaucoup changé ce rapport au
travail que demandent les salariés il
demande à avoir des weekends dans la
restauration et l'hôtellerie par exemple
c'est difficilement compatible donc les
restaurateurs se sont intelligemment
adapté moi je vois chez moi comme
partout ailleurs il y a des difficultés
de recrutement et bien on ouvre 4 jours
et on ferme 3 jours et on fidélise la
main d'œuvre donc il y a une
adaptabilité du marché du travail il
faut qu'on poursuive mais les Français
ne comprendraient pas pourquoi on ne
recrute pas prioritairement chez ceux
dans notre pays qui sont en demande
d'emploi et puis évidemment l'arrivée de
travailleurs mais là il s'agit pas de
avec cette mesure là quand même pour
bien comprendre il y a 500000 emplois à
pourvoir non pourvu c'est pas 500000
régularisations hein fantabéreté ce
n'est pas 500000 régularisation parce
que c'est vrai que ça pourrait laisser
penser que c'est ça que prévoyait le
texte non mais je pense qu'il faut qu'il
faut être sérieux moi je suis
complètement d'accord avec mes collègues
des républicains sur le fait que un pays
puisse choisir la manière dont il
souhaite gérer sa politique migratoire
et je pense que effectivement il y a eu
un certain nombre de texes exte cours
des dernières années moi j'étais pas
encore dans l'arène politique et que
comme chaque Français à chaque fois
qu'un texte est représenté je me suis
dit bah tiens encore là on avait à faire
face à deux problématiques renforcer un
certain nombre de mesures qui nous font
défaut aujourd'hui concernant les
aspects plus liés à la sécurité donc ça
c'est important et également tout ce qui
est en lien avec les enjeux économiques
oui aujourd'hui nous avons effectivement
encore un certain nombre d'emplois qui
non pourvu mais force de constater que
malgré en tout cas les efforts qui ont
été fait dans un certain nombre de
secteurs vous citez le la la
restauration mais également dans les le
bâtiment travaux les bâtiments travaux
publics on a amélioré les conditions de
travail mais on ne peut pas forcer nos
jeunes ou même nos moins jeunes à aller
sur des emplois sur lesquels ils n'ont
pas envie d'aller et nous avons à côté
de ça aujourd'hui nous nous nous mettons
des ornières mais dans un certain nombre
de secteurs des personnes qui sont là
depuis un certain nombre d'années qui se
lèvent tous les matins pour aller faire
de la plongche pour aller au chantiers
des gios et qui sont déjà
là par pas de 500000 personnes non
lesziffr alors selon les chiffres donc
avancés parce que c'est vrai que papier
qui sont déclar qui sont déclarés donc
moi le chiffre que j'ai retenu c'est
environ on va dire si je je je fais une
moyenne 12000 personnes
dont d'ailleurs la moitié serait situé
en à Paris île-de-fance et pour lesquels
en fait les associations sont là
également pour le dire les employeurs
sont là aussi pour le dire hein certains
ont fait des tribunes ont fait des
pétitions nous devons trouver une
solution vous dites oui à la
régularisation de ces 12000 qui
travaillent déjà mais non comme le dit
Bruno Le Maire à l'appel de mainœuvre
étrangère pour au fond ce qui voudrait
venir et ça vous pensez que ça veut
marcher c'estàdire le stock pour parler
de façon on va dire un petit peu
abstraite mais pas le flux je pense
qu'on a une solution à trouver à
plusieurs niveaux il y a l'urgence
actuelle nous avons ce texte et cette
possibilité de faire rentrer un certain
nombre de mesures ensuite il y a le
moyen terme le moyen terme c'est
travailler sur nos filières avec Madame
Genevard travaillons sur les métiers
liés au luxe et petites mains par
exemple c'est ces métiers manuels sur
lesquels en fait nos jeunes ont du mal
en fait à se projeter au démar
et bien là nous avons une refonte qui
est faite en fait des filières
professionnelles celle-ci et bien
d'autres de façon à ce qu'ell soit plus
attractive et aussi que les gens
puissent se projeter dans des dans une
filière et pas se dire je vais faire tel
métier qui est peu payé pendant 40 ans
ça c'est inadmissible et le dernier
point si vous me
permettez c'est juste le le long terme
avec effectivement aussi tout ce qui
concerne la politique familiale et
d'ailleursard Berger a entamé un tour de
France de la parentalité parce que force
de constater qu'aujourd'hui les Français
ont du mal à se projeter dans une F
familiale parce qu'on a ce choc
démographique hein dont on parle depuis
des années qui va arriver au moment où
moi par exemple j'arriverai à la
retraite est-ce qu'on aura assez de
cotisant et donc il faut également
travailler sur ça pour que dans quelques
années on soit stabiler des Français
mais sans exclure la régularisation de
ceux qui ont déjà un travail c'est ça la
position de de la majorité Briss vous
vous en cachez pas vous vous êtes un des
architectes de cette tribune
transpartisane qui avait poussé autour
de
sachaoulier renaissance commission des
lois mais aussi les écologistes les
socialistes sur cette idée d'intégrer
par le travail avec on va dire la
version initiale du texte aujourd'hui
quand vous voyez que vos vos amis ont
déposé cette motion de rejet motion de
rejet écologiste et qu'on en revient à
une version bien plus durcie que tout le
monde l'a bien compris vous vous vous
dites pas que c'est l'arroseur arrosé ah
si mais ça ça les regarde saz je je
pense qu'on n pas beaucoup d'amis dans
la période he avec exception je pense
que les entreprises ont pas beaucoup
d'amis je pense que les hommes et les
femmes de ce pays étranger qui ont envie
de travailler n'ont pas beaucoup d'amis
je pense que le salut la vitalité de
notre pays n'ont pas beaucoup d'amis je
je je on est on est on marche sur la
tête dans quel état d'esprit vous êtes
après ce qui s'est passé sur j'essaie
de je je suis terriblement inquiet de
de ce côté horsol de de ces débats
politiques par rapport à ce qui se vit
dans le pays euh parce que on marche sur
la tête c'est-à-dire que vous pouvez pas
entrer les parlementaires le savent
parce qu'elles sont dans la vraie vie en
tant qu'élu elles peuvent pas entrer
dans une boulangerie comme chez moi en
région parisienne elles peuvent pas
aller voir un patron d'une petite
entreprise un président de fédération
nationale patronal sans qu'il disent bah
là on va pas y arriver et la démographie
française que parler bien mieux que moi
le dit et la démographie européenne donc
on a cela et on a pardonnez-moi mais on
a dans nos association partout des
hommes et des femmes qui travaillent et
qui n'ont pas de papier des hommes et
des femmes qui demain pourrai travailler
des hommes et des femmes français dont
nous savons et je pense que vous le
savez qu'en réalité on va pas comme
Monsieur le Maire décréter que demain
ils vont se mettre au boulot nous savons
nous parce que nous voyons les unes et
les autres les uns et les autres que le
retour vers le travail c'est toute une
une action d'accompagnement pour des
hommes et des femmes cabossé par la vie
qui ont des problèmes de formation des
femmes seules qui peuvent pas faire
garder leurs enfants des bamans âgés
dont les parents sont malades donc moi
je voudrais simplement que les uns et
les
autres prennent la mesure de ce qui se
passe dans ce pays ce pays est travaillé
par des inquiétudes sur l'immigration
contrairement effectivement à certains
qui ont fait des grands discours pendant
cette motion pour expliquer qu'il y
avait aucun problème moi je ne crois pas
ça et donc cette proposition initiale du
gouvernement elle était elle avait le
mérite d'existé de régalisation dans les
métiers attention elle était fort timide
hein c'était c'était quand même un droit
opposable c'était un droitos un droit
opposable auprès fait euh qui donc avec
une possibilité de recours pour le
salarié
irrégulier rfendu au nom de nos
association avec un certain nombre de
parlementaires de la majorité de
l'opposition et j'engage fortement euh
la majorité parce que comme on sait pas
exactement où est le gouvernement et la
majorité dans tout ça un peu de
conviction fera du bien à tout le monde
qu'ils aillent jusqu'au bout que il y
ait des éléments d'accè au jeis qu'on
regarde par exemple l'avant après parce
que c'est important c'est assez
technique l'avant version Sénat l'après
version Sénat on est passé d'un droit
automatique ou un droit opposable à la
régularisation avec 8 mois de salaire à
justifier 3 ans de présence à après
passage au Sénat regularisation à la
discrétion du préfet donc au cas par cas
si 12 mois de de salaire justifié et
toujours 3 ans de résidence en France
ané jeunevard l'article Sénat on appelle
ça l'article 4 bis vous considérez qu'il
est équilibré aujourd'hui vous vous êtes
prêt à à dire oui parce qu'au fond il y
aura quand même des régularisations par
le préfet même si ça n'est pas la
version initiale quand les conditions
sont requises et d'une certaine façon ce
sera lui qui aura le dernier mot la
position des réublain vous le savez elle
est connue nous souhaitons revenir à la
version qui est sortie du Sénat donc
effectivement c'est le principe selon
lequel nous avons affaire à une
admission exceptionnelle au séjour pour
travail laissé à la discrétion du préfet
aujourd'hui avec la circulaire dite
circulaire Vals il y a à peu près 7000
personnes par an c'est à 10000 personnes
qui sont régularisées à certaines
conditions qui c ces conditions seront
plus exigeantes dans la la nouvelle loi
si elle est adoptée
euh il faudra attester qu'on a un casier
judiciaire vierge qui a pas de problème
qu'on est intégrable parce que au fond
le travail intègre mais il y a pas que
le travail qui intègre faut aussi la
volonté personnelle de vouloir
s'intégrer on voit bien que notre notre
société aujourd'hui elle est travaillée
par le communautarisme le séparatisme
par une certaine violence tout n'est pas
attribuable aux étrangers je ne veux pas
être caricaturale mais enfin on voit
bien aujourd'hui quiil a beaucoup de
tension notamment dans la 3è génération
issue de l'immigration qui semble avoir
beaucoup plus de difficultés par endroit
et à s'intégrer à accepter les règles
quand je vois que un jeune musulman sur
deux considère que la charia est
supérieure au lois de la République il y
a vraiment un gros problème
d'intégration de notre pays donc nous ce
que nous ne voulions pas ce que nous ne
vouli par ailleurs par ailleurs on qu'on
a à peu près entre 700 et 900000
étrangers irréguliers dans notre pays
500000 étrangers réguliers qui rentrent
chaque année je crois qu'on n pas en on
peut pas ignorer ces chiffres ils sont
extrêmement
important comme jamais ils ne l'ont été
et la réalité que décrivait PASC BR le
boulanger mais c'est la raison
nous assumons nous assumons et Monsieur
le sa puisque il a été un des principaux
responsables de l'ofreprin on a
aujourd'hui 70 % des demandeurs d'asile
qui sont qui ne sont pas éligibles à
l'asile et 96 % d'entre eux restent dans
une situation d'irrégularité donc tout
ça est à prendre en compte c'est pour ça
qu'il faut être clair et ferme pour
pouvoir mieux intégrer parce
qu'aujourd'hui on a une situation qui
est hors de contrôle alors ce que nous
ne voulions pas c'est que cette disp
position du gouvernement dans le projet
de loi du gouvernement créer un signal
un signal pour appel d' c'est c'est
l'expression qui est ressassé il est
convenu d'appeler un appel d'air par la
droite et l'extrême droite il y a des
gens mal intentionnés il y a des gens
mal intentionnés qui utilisent toutes
les dispositions légales pour pouvoir
abuser et moi je ne crois pas que ce
soit une marque d'humanité que de mettre
les gens sur des bateaux de fortune sur
les Z méiser ceux qui sont là et dans
les T de fortune et dans les tes de
fortune sur les trottoirs de nos villes
alors pour ceux qui donc ça c'est pour
éviter qu'il y ait des flux importants
qui arrive pour ceux qui sont
là je pense que les choses doivent se
gérer comme elles se gèent aujourd'hui
au cas par cas dans un cadre extrêmement
précis et très contrôlé ça doit être une
admission exceptionnelle au séjour et
puis il faut aussi et d'ailleurs en cela
beaucoup le disent on a aujourd'hui une
immigration familiale et sousqualifiée
il faut aussi qu'on puisse modifier le
profil des gens que nous acceptons sur
notre sol et c'est la raison pour
laquelle il faut le dire franchement
parce que parce que les capacités
d'intégration de la France ne sont pas
illimité il faut le dire aussi en tout
cas on voit très très clairement
politiquement parce qu'on est dans ce
temps-là aussi sur quoi il y a
potentiellement un compromis possible
c'est la version du Sénat à la virgule
près si je puis dire l'article B vous
vouliez
qui serait en je vais essayerputé
répondre mais ce ce compromis il c'est
pas du point de vue de ce qui importe
ici c'est-à-dire je crois hein
c'est-à-dire la vitalité de notre
économie et la sortie de la précarité de
de de de salariés ce compromis c'est
c'est rien c'est un recul par rapport
aux possibilités madame jeunbar l'a
présenté comme cela et elle a raison
contrairement à monsieur daranin qui a
essayé de dire tout et son contraire
dans cette affaire madame jeunbar a
raison de dire que ce sera puisque c'est
revendiqué un recul par rapport aux
possibilités actuelles de régularisation
offerte par la circulaire Vals donc si
c'est ça que qui est utile pour le pays
il faut le dire moi je suis je je le dis
à Madame jeunevard
avec une tristesse infinie parce que ce
pays moi je suis un peu grandi dans un
pays de avec des républicains de tout
bord et ce
glissement dont le Sénat dans le vote du
Sénat récent marque une apogée qui en
réalité dit quoi le Sénat il vous dit
pas contrairement à ce qu'on a voulu
croire il faut être un peu plus ferme
que machin que Darmanin je ne sais qui
d'autre ou bon non il vous dit
l'intégration c'est fini et pourquoi et
Madame jeunevard on a donné une
illustration et c'est le glissement du
débat public depuis un moment moi je le
dis parce que j'aimerais bien qu'à
moment not on prenne la mesure de ce que
l'on dit on par de la question de
l'immigration puis on arrive à la 3è
génération puis on parle des musulmans
donc disons les choses franchement tes
que le Sénat l'a dit le Sénat nous dit
ces gens-là parce qu'ils sont musulmans
ou parce que c'est la couleur de leur
peau c'est fini l'intégration donc je
préfère que ce soit dit comme ça moi je
vous redis que je considère que vu de
nos associations il y a des questions
posées sur l'intégration dans ce pays
moi je fais pas partie des gens qui ont
fait des discours pendant cette motion
de rejet pour dire il y a aucune
question dans l'immigration dans le pays
ça n'est pas vrai il y a des tensions y
compris sur la question de l'islam mais
moi je ne peux pas
accepter que l'on soit dans une forme
d'essentialisme qui veut que parce que
ces gens sont musulmans au couleur de
peau différent il serait pas intégrbl
vous répondez làd oui là là enfin bon
vous
savez j'entends votre colère et
votre il y a un peu désespoir làin
plutôt on vit des réalités différentes
on est des responsables politiques on
doit prendre des décis le pays notre
pays n'est pas le même madame mais vous
savez moi je suis petite fille d'immigré
italien oui cette question de
l'immigration je l'ai connu dans ma
famille bien donc j'estime avoir une
expérience qui n'est certainement pas
celle que qui est la vôtre mais de de
mon point de vue du point de vue de mon
histoire personnelle je peux dire un
certain nombre de choses oui de la
mienne aussi en tant que fils d'immigré
maintenant voilà
donc ce qui fait que nous sommes à
l'image de ce pays je crois je qu'on a
tous un peu de s'en mêler autour de
cette
table ça n'est plus possible non mais
vous ne pouvez pas dire ça ça n'est
pas compris des gens pour lesquels comme
vous j'ai beaucoup de respect
par je ne comprends pas je vais vous
dire je je partage votre avis faut pas
aliser les choses et il faut pas dire
étranger donc délinquant étranger donc
musulmans étranger donc radicalisés là
je vous rejoint parfaitement ça je je
pense je ne crois pas enfin si je vous
ai donné ce sentiment j'en suis désolé
parce que ça n'est pas mon s j' suis
convaincu Mame mais je suis convaincu
aussi que notre pays est en grand danger
de fracturation vous propose une petite
pause on va regarder je vous promets que
je vous donne la parole juste après mais
on a comme on n pas notre invité
restaurateur on va regarder cette
illustra de terrain à la fois dans le
bâtiment et puis dans la restauration
c'est grâce aux équipes de France 3 midi
pyrénée qu'on a pu vous montrer ce
reportage
regardez dans la cuisine de cette
brasserie deux salariés sur TR sont des
travailleurs étrangers malgré les
contraintes de la restauration ils
apprécient leur job je fais parce que
j'aime la cuisine et après des fois on n
pas trop le choix de choisir ce qu'on ve
faire Mohamed garagiste de formation
s'est même pris de passion pour ce
nouveau
métier ça te donne l'envie aussi de
coner ce métier moi franchement je
voudrais la prise de connaissance dans
ce métier pour PIR un jour devenir
peut-être chef leur patron ne pourrait
plus se passer de ses salariés étrangers
il aimerait que le gouvernement facilite
les démarches administratives pour les
garder aujourd'hui impossible de trouver
de la main d'œuvre un cher cuisinier des
employés ils veulent plus ils ont vu
qu'il y avait une autre vie voilà on
respecte cela mais à l'heure actuelle on
trouve plus aucune personne qui veut
venir travailler et donc eux sont
demandeurs et donc on les embauche et
puis c'est des personnes de confiance il
y a pas de souci il font très bien leur
travail autre secteur et même difficulté
pour recruter avance un peu là moins qu
cette entreprise du bâtiment emploie
depuis plusieurs années un ou plusieurs
salariés étrangers et tout le monde y
trouve son compte moi parle pas je
comprends pas bien français maintenant
je comprends bien mais j'aime bien aussi
le travail à sentier comme ça en 5 ou 6
ans qu'on travaille ensemble jamais un
retard jamais malade jamais toujours
opérationnel ça ça fait du bien beaucoup
on peut toujours compter sur eux en zone
rurale permettre de faciliter l'emploi
des travailleurs sans papier une idée
qui fait de plus en plus son chemin
voilà c'est intéressant parce que là on
parle de zone rurale euh vous parliez
tout à l'heure de de la périphérie de
Paris donc il y a des des territoires et
c'est où des besoins sont voilà sont
importants et et les territoires très
très différents euh qu'est-ce que
comment vous allez faire dans dans la
majorité parce qu'on est dans un temps
très politique qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
que vous êtes prêt à accepter qu'est-ce
que vous êtes prêt qu'est-ce que vous
n'êtes pas prêt à accepter quelles sont
vos lignes rouges parce que là je pense
que an jeunev c'était au moins mérite
d'être clair on a bien compris euh sur
quoi pourrait atterrir un compromis sur
cet article précis je pense que nous
comme dans tous les groupes je pense que
depuis cette semaine on se regroupe
parce qu'effectivement il y a
différentes
sensibilités donc au sein de de cette
majorité moi je fais partie des députés
qui avaient signé par exemple la tribune
donc qui était apparu porté par
notamment Stella Dupont et sachaoulier
et et pour vous le dire très clairement
si c'est l'article Calbis qui sort de
cette CMP vous votez ou vous votez pas
le texte pour l'instant en fait au jour
là à 7h précise je ne sais pas moi j'ai
envie simplement de dire aux
républicains je ne peux pas concevoir
que les députés qui vont représenter ce
groupe et sénateurs entre en se disant
en fait on ne bougera pas d'un yota je
pense que on a un chemin à parcourir que
les Français ne nous pardonnerai pas en
fait qu'on n'it pas de de CMP conclusive
et d'ailleurs on on découvre dans le
cadre de cette mandature t les
différents aspects voilà les sondages le
mon donc moi comme tous les députés
Renaissance nous travaillons sur
nous-mêmes nous rediscutons avec les
associations sur lesquelles avec
lesquels nous avions travaillé dans les
cadrees d'amendements que nous avions
aussi déposé comme les autres les autres
partenaires donc l'idée c'est de pouvoir
faire en sorte de tomber d'accord
dimanche soir et de donner mandat à nos
députés quiont autour de la table vous
voulez réagir oui trois trois petits
points rapides d'abord je voudrais comme
donner l'exemple de l'Allemagne
l'Allemagne vous vous rappelez la la
politique d'Angela Merkel qui était
virchafendas c'est-à-dire on accueille
massivement des réfugiés syriens tout
simplement pour les sauver de la mort
que Assad leur promettait et il y a eu
beaucoup de rétiscence des mouvements
effectivement de protestation le groupe
pgida d'extrême droite qui réagissait et
puis quelques années après la
Confédération industrielle allemande a
dit ces immigrés qui sont venus syriens
c'était un plus extraordinaire ça
apporté une productivité un élément de
compétitivité à l'Allemagne absolument
exception
prière remarque deuxième remarque il y a
parfois des signaux que je trouve
parfois un peu troublants je pense que
si nous sommes d'abord européens
démocrate républicain je pense que nous
devons cultiver les valeurs de la
société ouverte alors je veux pas dire
qu'il faut être une société ouverte à
tout vent qu'on accepte n'importe qui
comme disait Michel Rocard tous les
malheurs du monde bien sûr une société
ouverte ça veut dire une société voilà
d'abord qui soit quand même généreuse
qui soit accueillante qui ne cherche pas
à un certain moment des prétextes pour
refluer les personnes et je pense que ça
c'est quand même très important parce
que derrière on voit aussi au sein de
l'Europe au sein même on voit d'A aussi
aux États-Unis avec l'ire du mur et
cetera on voit un certain nombre de
mouvements qui personnellement
m'inquiète beaucoup et puis troisème
remarque rapide et là on n pas le temps
d'en parler mais nous allons vivre dans
les prochaines décennies dans un monde
de migration et ça c'est la réalité les
migrations je dirais il faudra les gérer
il faudra les accompagner il faut on ne
pourra pas l'idée qu'on va avoir des
barrières absolues je pense que c'est
quelque chose qui tient pas la route sur
le plan tout Simp de la politique
internationale an je va moi je voudrais
dire
que un peuple c'est un territoire c'est
une histoire c'est des valeurs communes
partagées et pour ça il faut pouvoir
intégrer à Rome fait comme les Romains
voilà aujourd'hui c'est ça qui est en
panne alors bien sûr on peut prenner une
vision généreuse et ouverte nous
voudrions retrouver cette cette légèreté
qui nous permettait d'accueillir l'autre
dans sa diff différence voilà mais
aujourd'hui le sujet n'est plus là
aujourd'hui d'abord beaucoup de gens
sont sur notre territoire sans en avoir
demandé l'autorisation vous ne pouvez
pas vous installer dans un pays sans en
avoir demandé l'autorisation or
aujourd'hui c'est la situation que nous
vivons donc moi je pense qu'il faut
quand même rétablir des règles de façon
à pouvoir organiser les choses
aujourd'hui elles ne sont plus
organisées du tout et et ça crée des
tensions vous développer une vision un
peu udylique mais mais sur le terrain on
voit bien les événements dramatiques qui
se sont produits récemment montre bien
que ces tensions elles sont elles
fracturent notre société et elles
éteignent aussi cette c c cet accueil et
on va s'arrêter là parce qu'on va
laisser les parlementaires cheminées ce
genre de débat peut-être peuvent y
contribuer même si évidemment il y a le
H cl des négociation peut-être le mot de
la fin Pascal Briss peut-être parce que
vous vous croyez pas à cet appel à cet
argument de l'appel d'air beaucoup de
Français y sont sensibles qu'est-ce que
vous pouvez dire qu' puisse très
clairement rationnellement par exemple
sur cette affaire de la régularisation
euh c'est assez simple à partir du
moment où vous êtes dans les secteurs en
tenstion c'est pour ça que contrairement
à pas mal de gens dans le monde
associatif ou à certains politiques moi
je je pense qu'effectivement l'approche
par les secteurs intention là on a des
besoins et la bonne approche parce que
ça év moi j'ai jamais défendu des
régularisations générales y compris
parce que je partage le constat de
Madame jeunevard mais comme je vois les
besoin Besin comme je vois le besoin
aussi de la vitalité de notre société et
bien à partir du moment où vous êtes
dans les secteurs en tension vous pouvez
très bien intégrer les gens par le
travail sans provoquer quoi que ce soit
je vous donne un exemple très rapide
pour terminer hein Ren des associations
extraordinaire qui travaill depuis des
années avec le mdeef avec le patronat
pour l'accès à la régularisation
certains parlementaires ont accepté de
porter une proposition d'amendement de
la face construite avec ces gens-là pour
que certaines régions françaises
puissent expérimenter ça en partant des
besoins des bassins un emploi des
associations des entreprises voilà je
Souha on peut faire du surmesure la fois
en fonction des attentes de l'économie
quoi que ce soit mais sans appel d'
chacun se fera son son opinion va
laisser les les parlementaires voilà
prendre le temps de la de la négociation
merci à vous vous restez avec moi
Nicolas Tenzer dans une dizaine de
minutes les partis prix de nos
affranchis ce soir où est Alexy Navalni
Isabelle lasser revient sur la
mystérieuse disparition du principal
opposant à Vladimir Poutine attendev
nous propose une autre lecture de la
polémique autour de ce tableau qui a
choqué les collégiens dissous dans les
Yvelines et puis quel est le programme
de Bourbon Express ce soir àamond
d'agava vous avez commencé à l'évoquer
myiam 14 parlementaires la recherche
d'un compromis c'est lundi à 17h c'est
la CMP à tout à l'heure les amis mais
d'abord on va revenir sur qui sur ce qui
se joue en ce moment même à Bruxelles
avec vous Nicolas Tenzer le chon le
chantage du hongrois Victor Orban
finalement n'aura pas porté ses fruits
le Premier ministre de la Hongrie a
retiré ce qui était véritablement des
des menaces et on verra pourquoi lui qui
Paris souvent sur le début d'une
lassitude sur l'Ukraine est-ce qu'on en
est là est-ce que l'Occident va
continuer à aider l'Ukraine Vladimir
Poutine lui aussi s'est exprimé tout
cela on le voit en image dans
l'invitation de Maité Frémont et on en
parle juste
après si on vous invite Nicolas Tenzer
c'est pour avoir votre analyse sur de
événements qui se télcopent aujourd'hui
dans l'actualité d'un côté Vladimir
Poutine qui bombe le torse dans sa
grande conférence de presse annuelle à
Moscou tandis qu'à Bruxelles se joue
l'avenir de l'Ukraine dans l'Union
européenne Nicolas Tenzer vous êtes
enseignant à Sciences Po spécialiste des
sujets de
géopolitique à la télévision russe
Poutine s'est donc lancé dans un
marathon de questions réponsse avec des
journalistes et des citoyens le maître
du cremelin qui a récemment annoncé
qu'il Brigit un nouveau mandat en 2024
assure que l'armée russe progresse
partout sur le front
ukrainien nous avons posé SEP condition
préala et selon l'évaluation de la
commission trois des SEP ne sont pas
remplis il n'y a donc aucune raison de
discuter de quoi que ce
soit discours qui a raisonné à 2200 km
de Moscou au sommet européen rendez-vous
crucial une semaine après le blocage des
aides par le Congrès américain au menu
le soutien européen à l'Ukraine 50
milliards d'euros promis et surtout
l'ouverture de négociation pour son
adhésion dans l'Union européenne de
décisions qui requier l'unanimité des 27
mais voilà d'entrée de jeu Victor Orban
donne le tempo ce
[Musique]
matin nous avons posé condition préal et
selon l'évaluation de la commission TR
des ne sont pas remplis il n'y a donc
aucune raison de discuter de quoi que ce
soit il y a 1h30 coup de théâtre Orban a
levé son double V l'Ukraine aura bien
l'aide de 50 milliards d'euros et
l'Union européenne a décidé d'ouvrir des
négociations d'adhésion avec le pays de
Zelinski alors ce soir une
question
comment expliquer cette voltef
d'Orban réponse réponse tout simplement
des questions d'argent
essentiellement il a besoin de l'Europe
bien sûr et il sait très bien il le sait
parfaitement donc il essaie de jouer
jusqu'au bout pour obtenir le maximum et
pour obtenir ce qui n'est pas sain du
tout par ailleurs une mensétude de la
part de l'Union européenne sur quand
même la l'affranchissement de plus en
plus visible de toute règles du droit
que ce soit la mise au pas des univers
ité le contrôle des médias on sait aussi
que le la Hongrie est le pays d'après
Transparency International le plus
corrompu de l'Union européenne est-ce
qu'on peut l'imaginer comme la
marionnette de Poutine en Europe ou
c'est exagéré non je pense que c'est un
cheval de tro mais il c'est vraiment un
cheval de tro potentiellement avec
d'ailleurs la Slovaquie partiellement je
vais le dire assez clairement l'Autriche
également mais bien sûr il peut pas non
plus aller jusqu'au bout et ça ça montre
aussi paradoxalement la force des
institutions européennes c'està-dire que
les gens qui sont dans l'Europe ont
besoin de rester dans l'Europe on est
dans quel moment Nicolas Tenzer
l'offensive la contreoffensive a plutôt
échoué de voladimir Zelenski on a vu ce
qu' a donné le Congrès américain le
Sénat républicain qui bloque l'aide
financière à Kief là ça n'est pas le cas
en Europe même si Orban a menacé de son
vetau ça n'est pas le cas les 50
milliards iront bien à Kief mais est-ce
qu'il y a de la lassitude est-ce que il
y a ce ce Paris qui est en train d'être
gagné par Poutine que l'Occident sera
fatigué à un moment de la guerre en
Ukraine je pense qu'il y a il y a
plusieurs choses d'abord je pense que le
discours défétiste c'est aussi une arme
de la propagande de Poutine c'est ça
aussi et on voit des propagandistes dans
différents pays européens qui disent
voilà l'Ukraine a perdu définitivement
si effectivement l'Ukraine a raté un
certain nombre de choses dans sa
contreoffensive il faut le rappeler
c'est essentiel parce que nos propres
livraisons d'armes au pays de l'Alliance
atlantique je parle pas de la France
spécifiquement ont été massivement
massivement
insuffisante massivement insuffisante il
faut savoir que les aides à l'Ukraine C
année par rapport à 2022 ont diminué de
90 % alors il y a eu comment vous
expliquez ça alors d'abord parce que
vous savez Emmanuel Macron le 13 juin
2022 à eurosator le grand salon de
l'armement avait dit il faut que les
économies des pay pays de l'Union
européenne se transforme en économie de
guerre nous ne l'avons pas fait alors
bien sûr nos industriels et les
industriels d'autres pays européens ont
augmenté leur production mais l'économie
de guerre c'est vraiment autre chose
alors que la Russie elle a réussi à le
faire que deuxièmement vous avez encore
des pays comme l'Allemagne par exemple
qui refuse de livrer des missiles à
longue portée les fameux ta russes
allemands la France le royaume les
avions de chasse voilà et est-ce que
vous imaginez une contreoffensive lancée
par un pays allié la France les
États-Unis sans avoir les trois
composantes suffisamment de chars il y
en a pas eu suffisamment des armes à
longue portée pour frapper l'ennemi dans
sa profondeur y compris sur le sol russe
ce qui est parfaitement légal en vertu
de l'article 51 de la Charte des Nations
Unies et bien sûr des avions de chasse
c'est impossible ou qu'est-ce que ça dit
de l'Europe quand on regarde le
Royaume-Uni par exemple et son son
volontarisme dans l'aide jamais
d'ailleurs remis en cause à Kief il y a
quand même une différence dans le
discours dans les actes qu'est-ce que ça
dit de l'UR elle aide mais pas assez
mais mais les États-Unis d'une certaine
manière qui on sont le premier
contributeur et qui donne plus de de 520
milliards quand même qui ont donné 150
milliards de dollars d'aide à l'Ukraine
quand on voit leur budget de la défense
qui est de 8000 milliards c'est
nettement supérieur on voit
effectivement des des sommes je dirais
les sommes ne sont pas adéquates quand
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'ils
n'ont pas pris la mesure pas pr la
mesure aujourd' gagne la guerre c'est
l'Europe tout entiè qui que nous sommes
à un moment décisif aujourd'hui nous
sommes al je sais pas si nous sommes en
39 ou en 41 mais c'est vraiment cela
c'est-à-dire que
aujourd'hui la victoire soit de
l'Ukraine soit de la Russie va
déterminer le futur de l'Europe dans les
décennies qui viennent de la même
manière que la victoire des alliés ou de
l'Allemagne Nazi je dirais on en est là
c'està-dire que vous avez derrière
Vladimir Poutine un projet de
destruction massive pas seulement de
l'Ukraine de la geéorgie qui est encore
occupé à 20 % du Bélarus de la la Syrie
on l'a vu mais nous avons un projet de
destruction totale je dirais de l'Europe
de nos principes de nos valeurs c'est
aussi pour ça que par rapport à nos
valeurs je pense qu'il faut tenir il
faut opposer à ce discours de Vladimir
Poutine totalement destructeur une autre
vision de l'Europe et ça c'est très
important auss s'interrompre un instant
pour prendre la température au sommet de
Bruxelles nous attend Richard verli
bonsoir Richard donc on a compris ce
soir on a on attendait la fumée blanche
seulement demain mais ce soir et bien
ctor Orban s'est couché et donc l'Union
européenne peut d'une façon solidaire
aider l'Ukraine et même lui ouvrir le
processus d'adhésion effectivement et
c'est intéressant ce que vous disiez
myiam parce qu'il y a eu une pirouette
de Victor Orban et elle a été physique
il n'était pas dans la salle du Conseil
européen au moment où a été acté
l'ouverture des négociations d'adhésion
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait concrètement et
bien il s'est abstenu il n'a pas mis son
véau mais il va pouvoir retourner en
Hongrie en disant qu'il n'a pas
participé au vote c'est tout à fait
Orban c'est un show politique qui
consiste en permanence à se présenter
comme celui qui défend les intérêts de
la Hongrie coûte que coûte mais au
dernier moment il laisse faire les
décisions parce qu'il ne veut pas se
retrouver isolé et comme l'a très
justement dit Nicolas Tenzer la Hongrie
a besoin de l'Union européenne merci
infiniment merci à vous et bon sommet à
très vite sur ce plateau à Paris Richard
l'adhésion ça c'est fondamental même si
ça prendra des années ouvrir la porte du
processus d'adhésion à
oui c'est fondamental de même que pour
la Moldavie et quand le pays sera libre
du Bélarusse je pense que ces pays
d'abord ont montré en terme de valeur en
terme de principe en terme de combat que
c'était des pays européens que leurs
peuples étaient européens déjà en
Ukraine depuis Maidan la révolution de
2014 elle s'est faite au nom des valeurs
vous savez très bien qu'il y a les
valeurs et elles ne sont pas négociables
et il y a les intérêts on voit déjà des
des voies montées sur la question
agricole la la compétition pourra
entraîner l'entrée de l'raine dans
l'Union
pour SAF que sauf que moi ce que je vois
ce sont les atouts que représentera
l'Ukraine d'abord c'est un pays moi je
suis allé trois fois en Ukraine depuis
le début de la guerre totale une
vingtaine de fois avant c'est un pays
innovant c'est un pays compétitif c'est
un pays dynamique c'est un pays avec une
jeunesse absolument extraordinaire et
qui a d'ailleurs montré par son courage
le courage de la Société des combattants
combien elle était profondément
européenne mais prête à se combattre à
ce Pr sur l'avenir je crois que ce sera
un pays qui va entraîner l'Europe
l'agriculture en fait je pense que ce
sera un atout en terme de puissance
européenne parce que l'agriculture
ukrainienne ça va pas tellement être une
compétition pour les fermiers français
polonais allemands ou que c'est ça va
être un atout pour l'extérieur
l'industrie et la rénovation de
l'industriel du potentiel industriel ça
va être un atout pour l'Europe les
nouvelles technologie d'ailleurs on
pourrait voir l'ingéniosité
extraordinaire des Ukrainiens même
d'ailleurs dans l'administration
électronique qui sont bien en avance sur
nous déjà avant la guerre et ça on
l'oublie toujours donc je pense que
c'est un pays qui non seulement va
porter la conscience de l'Europe dans
les années futures mais aussi va
entraîner son dynamisme l'Europe sera
plus forte on dit toujours qu'il faut
une taille critique et aujourd'hui
l'Europe n'a pas encore cette taille
critique je pense alors il y a des vrais
problèmes de coopération bien sûr le
marché unique n'est pas parfait mais je
pense que l'Ukraine va apporter cela et
ça va être une occasion aussi pour nous
de repenser l'Europe alors vous parlez
au futur mais ça va prendre des années
ça vous en convenez al pour moi pour moi
ça alors ce sera pas dans 2 ans suite je
pense que d'abord il faut effectivement
que la guerre se termine c'estàdire il
faut que nous nous gagnons la guerre ce
qui est notre guerre je crois qu'il faut
le dire le rébéter toujours c'est notre
c'est pas uniquement la guerre des
Ukrainiens bien sûr mais après quand on
voit déjà les progrès obtenus y compris
sur des sujets effectivement sensibles
sur l'Ukraine l'Ukraine était mal placée
comme la lutte contre la corruption il y
a déjà des problè moi je pense que ça
croyez encore franchement parce que tous
les reporters qui reviennent du donbas
vous disent que le moral des troupes est
quand même en berne du côté de la Russie
maintenant quand on a ces images de
Poutine aujourd'hui cette journée de
conférence de presse plus confiant que
jamais lui aussi il a perdu beaucoup
d'hommes mais il n'a pas beaucoup reculé
sur le terrain les sanctions européennes
qu'ont-elles donné ont-elles vraiment
asphixé la société Poutine s'est réfugié
vers son allié chinois est-ce que vous
avez le sentiment que presque 2 ans
après le rapport de force n'est pas
véritablement favorable au au chef du
kremelin alors aujourd'hui d'abord le
kremelin ne peut plus gagner ça c'est
parfaitement clair en revanche l'issue
de la guerre ça dépend de nous c'est
notre responsabilité et je pense que de
ne pas avoir fait assez c'est aussi
notre culpabilité vous évoquez très
justement la question des sanctions je
pense qu'elle mordent véritablement la
Russie mais pas suffisamment elles sont
contournées y compris en Europe vous
avez encore des entreprises même
françaises ce qui me paraît totalement
scandaleux qui qui travaille aujourd'hui
en Russie bon on ne fait pas également
au niveau européen parce qu'on y est
réticent pour des tas de raisons
absurdes on ne décide pas de sanctions
dites extraterritorial sur tous les pays
la Chine l'Inde les Émirats qui aide de
la Russie il faut aller de la donc on
est encore en ça de la main est-ce qu'il
se renforcé on est presque 2 ans après
il va se représenter Poutine pour un 5e
mandat on a l'impression que rien ne
l'arrête mais encore une fois c'est à
nous de l'arrêter bien sûr et je pense
que ça c'est vraiment un devoir
historique je pense que les chefs d'État
et de gouvernement européens américains
canadiens mais aussi des autres
démocraties d'Asie Japon Corée du Sud
Australie qui n'aide pas l'Ukraine je
crois vraiment commettre une faute
historique maintenant Poutine
effectivement il semble rasserrainé
peut-être mais la réalité aussi c'est
que l'économie russe est en lambau quand
vous voyez la mortalité pendant la crise
de la covid-19 l'état des écolesat des
infrastructures vous n'avez pas de ce
PME solide en Russie vous avez une
économie en perdition la grande pauvreté
augmente de manière absolument colossale
c'est une société détruite donc
l'histoire n'est pas finie l'histoire
n'est pas finie et je pense qu'on peut
absolument mais encore une fois c'est à
nous c'est notre responsabilité de
d'agir dans un sens encore une fois je
pense qui est vraiment qui est vraiment
celui de l'histoire et je me demande si
aujourd'hui on a pris la mesure je dis
les vous êtes là pour ça pour le
rappeler c'est notre et même si les
projecteurs sont braqués sur le proche
orient n'oublions pas l'Ukraine merci
beaucoup Nicolas Tenzer vous restez avec
moi parce que vous allez pouvoir réagir
au parti prix de nos affranchis qu'on
accueille tout de suite pour terminer
cette
émission allez Isabelle laasser du
Figaro excellente page Diplo et Nathan
de vert pour son billet philo
installez-vous on commence comme chaque
soir par Bourbon Express l'histoire du
jour à l'Assemblée nationale c'est Elsa
Elsa mingava bonsoir à vous qui nous la
raconte bonsoir je vais vous raconter
l'histoire de 14 personnes qui lundi ce
lundi 18 à 17h vont s'enfermer dans une
salle ils n'ont pas les mêmes opinions
politiques mais ils vont essayer de
rapprocher leur point de vue je vous
parle pas d'une nouvelle émission de
téléréalité ni d'une expérience
scientifique quoi que je vous parle de
la fameuse CMP la commission mixte
paritaire vous l'évoquiez avec vos
invités myiam regardez-les ces 14 élus
se députés SEP sénateurs on a les
présidents des commissions des lois de
chaque chambre les rapporteurs généraux
du projet de loi immigration des
représentants des groupes politiques en
fonction de leur poids et puis on
regarde justement ces poids ces
équilibres ces rapports de force cinq
représentants de la majorité
présidentielle face à cinq représentants
de la droite et du centre vous l'avez
compris en commission mixte paritaire la
majorité n'a pas la majorité si vous
suivez un peu la politique c'est bien
son problème depuis un an et demi il
faut donc convaincre à droite oui
évidemment Elsa on ne rentre jamais dans
une CMP sans avoir négocié en amont oui
sauf que d'habitude c'est ces
négociations elles se font un peu en en
coulisse là tout est public ellisabeth
born la première ministre qui a
ostensiblement repris le dossier elle
consulte elle reconsulte elle re
reconsulte regardez hier elle voyait les
dirigeants des républicains les voitures
rentrent à Matignon aujourd'hui elle les
a revu les voitures sortent de Matignon
ils n'y ont pas passé la nuit mais ils y
sont retournés elle a vu les
représentants de la majorité aussi et
puis évidemment tout le weekend les
téléphones vont se chauffer il y aura
des échanges très nombreux oui parce
qu'il y a beaucoup beaucoup de lignes
rouges hein pour les uns comme pour les
autres oui vous l'avez évoqué en partie
la question des régularisations des pour
les métiers en tension la question de
l'aide médicale d'État de la durée de
résidence pour bénéficier de certaines
allocations et la droite Myriam on l'a
vu avec Annie jeunevard aussi elle campe
sur ses positions regardez le tweet
d'Éric cioti avec Olivier marlex et
Bruno rotaillo nous avons ce matin
confirmé à la première ministre notre
volonté de voir le texte du Sénat adopé
adopté en commission mixte paritaire
htag immigration ce à quoi bah de
l'autre côté de la négociation on a une
majorité avec notamment son AG et
sachalier qui répond alors quelles sont
les chances d'aboutir alors les Chan d'
pas éc on va écouter un tout petit son
de sach allez le président de la
commission des lois pardonnez-moi dire
que c'est leur texte ou rien ce serait
droite ce serait dangereux pour la
commission mixte paritaire parce qu'une
commission mixte paritaire c'est un
endroit dans lequel les députés et les
sénateurs arrivent pour faire un
compromis voil et donc si personne ne
veut faire de compromis il ne peut pas y
avoir d'accord voilà on comprend que ça
va être très compliqué qu'il y a une
chance qu'elle soit conclusive comme on
dit cette commission mixte paritaire
parce que Emmanuel Macron a étit très
clair s'il ne conclut pas c'est tout le
texte qui est abandonné oui bah écoutez
Myriem je vais me je vais emprunter un
personnage célèbre ce conseil pour
conclure oublie que tu as aucune chance
vas-y fonce on sait jamais sur un
malentendu ça peut passer c'est pas un
homme politique c'est Jean-Claude dus
dans Les Bronzés conseil au
parlementaires pour le weekend voilà et
si Michel Blanc nous regarde total
respect je vais pas vous demander parill
c'est pas votre truc mais voilà vous
pensez que ça va marcher oui voilà voilà
allez on va écouter Isabelle lasser que
vous connaissez bien elle est faite pour
vous cette chronique Nicolas Tenzer
Isabelle vous nous parlez de de du
principal opposant de de Poutine Alexy
Navalni qui a disparu de sa prison
depuis plusieurs jours alors vous vous
souvenez Alexey Navalni c'est un des
opposants les plus
populaires de Russie c'est un de ceux
qui fait le plus peur à Vladimir Poutine
c'est un militant anticorruption il a 47
ans il a été empoisonné par le cremelin
il a été soigné en Allemagne il est
revenu en 2021 se jeter dans la gueule
du loup il a été arrêté condamné à 30
ans de prison dont 19 pour extrémisme ça
ne s'invente pas alors qu'est-ce qui lui
est arrivé alors depuis le 5 décembre il
a complètement disparu des écrans radars
il n'est plus enregistré dans sa prison
qui s'appelle ik6 qui est à 235 km à
l'est de Moscou il n'a pas assisté non
plus aux audiences par vidéo d'un
nouveau procès est-ce qu'on sait où il
est ce qui s'est passé alors est-ce
qu'il a été tué est-ce qu'il est tombé
gravement malade les conditions de
détention d'Alex Navalni sont très
difficiles de temps en temps il est
placé dans une cellule de 2 m/ 3 sans
ventilation il a perdu 20 kg en 2 ans et
quelques jours avant sa disparition il a
été pris de nombreux vertiges mais plus
probablement il a dû être transféré dans
une colonie pénitentiaire à régime
spécial ce sont les plus strictes il y
en a une trentaine en Russie et elles
sont installées dans les régions les
plus reculées du pays notamment à
Sibérie hm hm alors pourquoi maintenant
alors pour des raisons bien sûr pour des
raisons politiques tout est politique en
Russie et c'est justement la la la
disparition de de d'alexay Navalni
correspond justement à l'annonce de la
candidature de Vladimir Poutine un 5e
cand un 5e mandat et à l'annonce de la
date des élections qui auront lieu le 17
mars prochain or même en prison à
Navalni reste populaire puisque via ses
avocats en fait il fait passer des
messages sur les réseaux sociaux et ses
équipes à peine euh avait-on connu le
jour de la date des élections ont lancé
une campagne de panneau d'affissage pour
appeler la population à voter contre
Vladimir Poutine il faut donc le faire
disparaître le plus rapidement possible
et le plus loin possible ce n'est pas de
très bon augure parce que la répression
ne cesse de s'accentuer en Russie ou
plus une seule voix euh n'ose s'opposer
au pouvoir et tout ça se passe dans
l'indifférence relatif des Occidentaux
qui ont toujours soutenu Navalni mais
qui depuis le début de la guerre
d'Israël contre le Hamas ont les yeux
fixés sur le prochorient un mot de
réaction vous l'avez rencontré Navalni
non mais je connais d'autres dissidents
l'un est un ami très proche Vladimir
caramourza qui a été condamné à 25 ans
de prison l'un des dissidents les plus
importants qui était aussi chroniqueur
au Washington Post je pense à Ilia
Yashin je pense à yri dimitriev je pense
à tous ceux qui sont régulièrement
assassinés des militants même
écologistes des militants des droits de
l'homme des militants pour n'importe
quoi mais ça veut dire aussi que Poutine
a peur il a peur même s'il contrôle tout
même s'il va diriger les élections qu'il
n'y a pas de surprise il a peur et c'est
ça je pense une des leçons qu'il faut
retenir c'est un homme affaibli
profondément affaibli même s'il muscle
son discours et qu'il continue à
assassiner un peu partout dans le monde
allez on va terminer avec avec vous
Nathan devt ce soir vous nous proposer
une autre lecture de la polémique dans
ce collège d'ous dans les Yvelines
souvenez-vous une professeur de français
qui enseignait un passage des
métamorphoses d'Ovid le récit de Diane
et Actéon a montré ce tableau à ses
élèves un tableau de Césarie j'ai
d'ailleurs découvert le peintre
représentant Diane entouré de nymf
totalement nu comme vous le voyez ce qui
a provoqué la colère d'une partie de sa
classe oui exactement donc ce tableau
quand il a été montré dans un cours de
de français en en 6e il y a eu un
incident donc certains élèves ont refusé
de le voir ensuite il y a eu une colère
naissante de cette colère des rumeurs
sont apparu des rumeurs selon laquelle
selon lesquelles la professeur avait eu
des phrases racistes ce qui était faux
rumeur ensuite entretenu et cultivé par
les parents d'élèves et l'incident a
poussé la professeur à porter plainte
pour dénonciation calomnieuse l'ensemble
des professeurs du lycée a exercé leur
droit de retrait pour soutenir cette
professeur et puis il y a eu toute une
polémique qui a amené par exemple
Gabriel Atal à dénoncer des actes
inacceptables à dire queil fallait
absolument euh euh s'indigner du fait
que certains élèves a refusaient de voir
un tableau et puis on a vu dans le débat
public surtout beaucoup de gens nous
dire que c'était grave parce que la
culture euh était atteinte par une
nouvelle forme de puritanisme et on a
entendu beaucoup de gens rappeler à quel
point les œuvres d'art n'étaient pas
faites pour nous caresser dans le sens
du poil mais qu'elle devait nous heurter
nous choquer nous faire découvrir des
nouveaux horizons et parfois même au
risque de nous euh déranger et ça ce
sont des évidences salutaires non ce
sont des évidences salutaires sans doute
mais euh j'ai été un peu gêné par ce
genre de discours par ce genre
d'apologie euh qui invoque la culture
avec un grand C comme une sorte de mot
euh un peu abstrait comme une sorte de
catégorie générique que nous devrions
révérer uniquement parce que c'est la
culture comme si ce tableau du simple
fait qu'il appartenait à notre
patrimoine de l'histoire de l'art
européen euh devait appeler
nécessairement euh des réactions comme
ça euh d'adoration une sorte de
fétichisme formolisé de la culture qui
nous fait oublier ce qu'il y a
concrètement à l'intérieur de ce tableau
et ce tableau paradoxalement en fait on
va le revoir en même temps allez-y
allez-y pose toute une réflexion
aiguisée et inquiète sur ce que c'est
que de voir la nudité alors le mythe de
Diane et Actéon il nous vient d'vid du
livre 3 des métamorphose et c'est
l'histoire donc d'acctéon un chasseur
qui est l'incarnation de l'homme
tragique OV nous dit c'est un homme qui
a été perdu par le hasard une simple
erreur lui a donné un destin de criminel
il est en train de se promener dans la
forêt après une partie de chasse et pas
de chance il tombe sur Diane la déesse
qui est en train de se baigner avec ses
nymfes et qui est nu et donc il la voit
mais de manière involontaire et Dian
voyant qu'il la voit se met à rougi et
du simple fait qu'il a fait rougir la DS
d'an et bien il est maudit il est
transformé en serre et ses chiens de
chasseur le dévore et le tue et donc si
vous voulez le tableau du cavalier
d'arquin il nous d'Arpin et pardon il
nous donne une représentation en quelque
sorte impossible c'est qu'il nous invite
à nous mettre dans la position d'acctéon
c'est-à-dire de se dire on regarde
nous-même le corps de quelqu'un qu'on
qu'on voit nu en en en la prenant si
vous voulez contre son gré et que se
passe-t-il et donc il doit générer
un sentiment de malaise tantz si bien
que cette polémique il me semble que
elle est peut-être le symptôme d'une
forme d'allergie puritaine contre la
culture qui existe mais avant tout là où
c'est intéressant c'est qu'elle est une
répétition même de l'histoire du mythe
de Diane et de l'histoire en particulier
de ce tableau mais où c'est à l'envers
si vous voulez c'est Actéon lui-même qui
se voile les yeux ououi donc ceux qui
sont choqués finalement remplace un
Actéon qui lui ne voyait que une jolie
femme Simp exactement et avec une sorte
de double danger où certains n'aiment
pas la culture parce qu'elles les font
peur et d'autres la révèrent mais en la
fétichisant qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
mais je pense que ce qui serait très
intéressant c'est que les très belles
explications que vous avez donné ce soit
ces explications là qu' soit qu'elle
puissent elles soit fournie par le
professeur qu'elles soit expliquer et
que just vous êtes choqué comme Actéon a
pu l'être enfin en tout cas et je pense
que ça suscite un débat ce qui est
intéressant à l'école c'est c'est pas
tellement d'avoir une réponse finale
mais d'avoir ces débats et quand il n'y
a plus de possibilité de débat de
discussion de mise en perspective de
rapport à l'histoire y compris de
rapport à l'histoire de l'art de rapport
à la mythologie effectivement tout
devient binaire devent la et ça devient
totalement absurde merci beaucoup vous
le connaissiez ce tableau non moi je
l'ai découverti je le connaissais pas
ouai ben il est très beau merci les
affranchis merci Isabelle Nathan de vert
Isabelle lasser du figarou elsamondagava
vous serez là sans doute demain et toute
la semaine prochaine parce que il y a de
l'actualité à l'Assemblée lundi il y
aura une émission d'ailleurs avec
Brigitte boucher si la fumée blanche
sort de cette commission mixte paritaire
Merci à VOUS Nicolas Tenzer c'est la fin
de cette émission soirée documentaire à
présent avec Jean-Pierre Gratien pour la
voir ou la revoir celle-ci d'émission la
chaîne Youtube d'lcp bien sûr très belle
soirée à
[Musique]
demain